Continuing in Kitab al-wajiz fi Kitab
al-tahara
the book of purification.
So, yesterday we discussed
the topic of water
and
the various types of water and we
mentioned that
water
is one of two things.
It is either pure and purifying
or it has been corrupted
by
some filth
that has
diluted into it, that has dissolved into
it
to the point that it has corrupted it
and it has changed one or more of its
percep- perceptive
perceptible features.
So, it's smell,
it's color,
it's taste.
Two types of water.
Right? Remember the principle that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave
us.
Remember the
the
the well
the well of
that was on the outskirts of Medina
that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was asked about. A well called
It was positioned in a
poorly
set set place.
It was kind of in a valley. It was in an
off stream, and people when they would
come to Medina, travelers, they're
coming in, they're leaving, right? This
was a popular place for people to set up
their camp.
And as people do throughout history,
they leave various types of garbage
around their camp, especially in the
times of Jahiliyyah,
in the times when
people didn't have the decorum of Islam
that Islam teaches us.
And so,
you know, females would leave their
menstrual rags there. Men would
you know, wipe themselves after
relieving themselves or relieve
themselves in that area. And what would
happen is when it would rain, etc.,
would all go into this well.
And so,
, he was asked about the water from
that well.
And he gave us the principle, that is
He said, "Water is pure and it is
purifying essentially.
Nothing makes water impure."
Meaning
that unless it has been diluted by
something
that is impure to the point that it has
changed its color, taste, or smell,
then it is pure. So, there's two types
of water.
There's water which is pure and
purifying,
water which has been corrupted.
Right?
And when we say corrupted, we're
speaking about corrupted by filth,
corrupted by najasa.
Wherever it comes from, doesn't matter
where it originates from.
As long as it retains
its color,
taste, and smell,
which is neutrality,
or,
you know, its color, taste, and smell is
is that typical of water, it's pure.
And if it has been corrupted to the
point that something is diluted itself
into it,
,
some najasa, right? Then
it is not permissible to use. It is not
pure and it is not purifying.
Now, why do we put such an emphasis on
this? A lot of times you'll read in, ,
especially the
in the books of fiqh,
you'll find that another popular opinion
is
categorizing water into three
categories, not two, three.
We mentioned two here, right?
Pure
and impure.
Okay.
But, some scholars have written
that it is actually three categories.
So, pure water,
impure water, but they add a third,
which is water that has been diluted by
something that is not filthy,
but it has changed its nature.
What does that mean? let me say
for instance,
chicken broth.
What is chicken broth?
Chicken broth is when you take
chicken
and you boil it up and melt it in the
thing,
and the water
starts to change until now it's chicken
broth, right?
What is tea?
Tea is also you put tea in water, you
boil it, and it dilutes it until it
turns into tea. What is coffee? Coffee
is 99% water, right?
So, they would say, is it permissible
for a person to make wudu using tea,
coffee, chicken broth? The answer is no.
Of course not.
They say this water here,
it's not it's not impure,
but it's not purifying.
It has been diluted by something pure to
the point where it is no longer just
considered water.
However,
the reason that that is not the stronger
opinion
is because do we call tea
this is water with tea, or do we call it
tea?
We call it tea, right? Do we say this is
water
with coffee in it? Is that what we say?
Do we say this is water
with chicken broth in it. No, we call it
chicken broth. Its name has changed.
It's no longer water anymore.
Right?
Therefore, it's inconsequential. Once
its name changes,
it is no longer in the realm
of the the the topic of water. Now, it's
a different topic.
Clear?
So,
traditionally,
there are scholars that
categorize water into two categories,
pure and impure,
and others that say, "Well, it's pure,
impure, and
water that is you know, of
compounded nature. It's water and it's
something else what is pure, it's
diluted itself into it." So, once its
name has changed, it no longer has that
same ruling.
Right?
Because something's name changing
changes its ruling with it in in Islamic
law.
So, being that we understand that now,
we have water
that is pure and then water that is
impure.
We want to know now what are those
things that make water impure.
What are the types of najasa? What are a
najasat?
And so, the author now goes into this
topic, the topic of the
najasat, listing the various types of
najasa.
Now, remember when we were doing the
book of fasting,
we'd say, for instance, there are six
things that break a person's fast,
right? And we had a list, we memorized
it. Same thing here.
There are eight types of najasa, eight.
These eight types of najasa
that is our list. Anything outside of
this list
is not najasa.
Okay?
Now, it being
it being considered
it not being considered a type of najasa
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
clean.
Something may be unclean.
Right? Or unsightly or gross.
But, it doesn't necessarily mean that it
is a najasa.
Najasa in English, for our intents and
purposes, we are going to use the word
filth.
Filthy.
Okay?
There are things which are unclean.
Those are a lot of things.
And then there are eight types of filth.
Something is only considered filth
if it has been listed by a law or as
messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam. We
need an evidence
from the Quran and Sunnah or Sunnah
in order to list something as a type of
najasa.
We have to have evidence for it. Even if
it is
so blatant, right? human feces.
This is najis, right? This is filthy. We
all know this.
We all know this. This is
something which is considered to be
self-evident.
However, we still have to have evidence
for it for it to make this list.
Why do we need evidence for it? Because
we are building
is we are building laws
that rest upon this list.
Right? Things hinge on this list. A
person's prayer being valid, being
invalid,
a person be obligated to do something,
not obligated, haram and halal, all
hinge on this list.
So, therefore, being that laws of Allah
hinge on this list and are founded on
this list, we have to make sure that we
have an evidence from the Quran and
Sunnah for every single type of
filth that we list here
in this section. So,
this now is going to be the part where
we get into the various types of najasa.
And najasat, those types of filth that
exist. Remember, there are eight and
inshallah ta'ala, we will begin that
list tomorrow. Nas'alullah subhanahu wa
ta'ala bimannihi wa karamihi wa judih an
[Arabic recitation]